contrairement à ce qu'il se passe pour
la France lorsqu'on parle de la fin de
l'Empire britannique la postérité nous
lègue le plus souvent l'image d'une
décolonisation sans heure d'une
décolonisation exemplaire la réalité
pourtant apparaît tout autre c'est en
tout cas la démonstration que vient de
nous livrer ce documentaire tiré de la
série les coulisses de l'histoire en
nous rappelant qu'au-delà de la vitrine
du commonwes la Couronne britannique n'a
le plus souvent lâcher ses possessions
coloniales qu'au prix du sang et des
larmes de quoi s'interroger sur les
sombre de la décolonisation des grands
empires après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant en compagnie de nos deux
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc Mélanie toran pour commencer
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur en
histoire et civilisation britannique et
histoire du commonwes à l'université
Picardi Jul Verne et puis également avec
nous Pascal Blanchard bienvenue à vous
Pascal Blanchard vous êtes historien
spécialiste du fait colonial et auteur
entre autres de décolonisation franç
française la chute d'un empire un
ouvrage préfacé d'ailleurs on va le
souligner par Benjamin Stora qui est un
ouvrage que vous avez co-écrit avec
Nicolas banscel et Sandrine Lemer il est
disponible aux éditions La Martinière
mlanie torent il convient sans doute de
recontextualiser tout ce qu'on a vu dans
ce documentaire vous étiez conseillère
historique sur le film que nous venons
de voir nous sommes donc après guerre
c'est le début de la guerre froide et au
pouvoir en Grande-Bretagne mais aussi en
France hein d'ailleurs des hommes qui
sont imprégnés de cet empire colonial
qu'il soit britannique ou français on va
commencer par Winston churchield côté
britannique évidemment le général de
Gaulle du côté français Winston
Churchill quelle est son attitude à la
sortie de cette seconde guerre mondiale
vis-à-vis de l'avenir des colonies
britanniques alors pour Churchill
effectivement il est à la fin de la
guerre euh l'homme le le grand leader de
la la nation et de de l'Empire
britannique qui a gagné la guerre face à
une Europe qui était dans une
situation absolument catastrophique donc
qui qui en ressent une supériorité non
seulement pour la Grande-Bretagne mais
pour l'Empire et le Commonwealth qui
vont avec donc c'est sûr que pa win
Churchill dont les grands discours
d'ailleurs vente finalement le
l'adhésion de l'Empire et du commonwes
d'ailleurs dans ces années-là les deux
termes se trouvent très souvent ensemble
et montrent que c'est une vision
réellement
impériale du du
monde international qui persiste donc
pour Churchil doit y avoir une une
continuité parfaite alors ce qui est
particulièrement peut-être intéressant
et important de
souligner quand on réfléchit donc à la
Grande-Bretagne ce moment très important
très trouble aussi entre eux de de
sortie de de guerre mondiale en fait
c'est que Churchill et les conservateurs
vont perdre les élections législatives
de de 1945 c'est les travaillistes qui
vont arriver au pouvoir et si la vision
de l'Empire est différente côté
travailliste il y a absolument pas de
euh d'engagement politique ni même en
fait de réelles conviction individuelles
ou euh ou ou collectif j'allais dire de
mettre fin à l'empire il y a des
ambitions de de réforme euh donc dont on
pourra peut-être parler mais ça reste
l'idée d'un monde euh impérial et bien
sûr il faut pas oublier que la fin de la
euh que la Seconde Guerre mondiale a été
pour les Britanniques aussi une
reconquête de l'empire d'un empire qui
avait été attaqué qui avait été perdu à
Singapour en Malaisie et donc la la
victoire passe aussi par une reconquête
coloniale par rapport à ce ressenti côté
britannique à cette vision de Winton
Churchill notamment que dire de de De
Gaulle à peu près la même chose de
Gaulle va pas rester très longtemps au
pouvoir mais il aura le temps de rebâtir
ce qui peut être les fondements
coloniaux qui lui paraissent essentiels
inévitaable incontournable pour que la
France reste une grande nation
d'ailleurs les opérations anadochine
s'engage immédiatement après la
libération du territoire et les affiches
même sort tout de suite il faut
retrouver l'indochchine pour retrouver
la grandeur française la répression en
Algérie de 8 mai 45 comme en Syrie avec
le bbardement de Damas montre bien cette
volonté de ne perdre aucune des parties
de l'empire je dirais même que très tôt
avec la conférence de Brazaville
rappelez-vous on est début 44 il y a
cette volonté d'annoncer des réformes
même si ces réformes entreront peu en
pratique cette idée qu'il faut changer
sans rien changer cette idée qu'il faut
continuer avec l'Empire d'avant même si
on sait qu'il été bouleversé par la
guerre n'oublions pas que comme pour les
Britanniques la France par exemple a vu
l'indochchine occupée par les japonais
mais les Français n'imaginent pas et là
à peu près toute la classe politique
n'imaginent même pas que la grandeur de
la France la continuité de la France la
4e République pourrait se prolonger
continuer s'installer dans cette Europe
et ce monde qui rentre dans la guerre
froide sans son empire on va voir un
premier extrait du film il est question
évidemment de la partition de l'Inde
nous sommes en
1947 commence alors un déplacement de
population sans
[Musique]
précédent
entre 12 et 16 millions de personnes
vont se croiser sur les chemins de
l'exil les musulmans quittent l'Inde
pour rejoindre le Pakistan les Sikhs et
les hindou fui dans le sens
inverse d'innombrables victime périssent
en route de fatigue de faim ou de
maladie la partition hative et
arbitraire de l'Inde provoque une
tragédie qui se solde par plus d'un
million de morts
alors le titre de ce documentaire
c'était décolonisation britannique l'art
de filer à l'anglaise alors ce qui s'est
passé en Inde qui est quand même le le
joyeux de la couronne hein de l'Empire
britannique ça illustre parfaitement ce
titre 1 million de victimes suite à
cette partition décidé un peu
arbitrairement si on a bien compris ce
qui qui est dit dans ce film à l'issu de
cette partition c'est considérable et
c'est sans doute cette période de la
décolonisation britannique qui est la
plus meurtrière or or la postérité nous
nous nous dit que effectivement ça a été
une décolonisation exemplaire de ce qui
s'est passé en Inde absolument alors
effectivement le le documentaire montre
bien les les
conséquences à la fois humaines
absolument tragiqu et puis ce qu'on a
aussi en arrière-fond les conséquences à
long terme géopolitiques puisque il y a
des les les les britanniques partent
avant qu'un certain nombre de questions
dont par exemple celle du Cachmir ne
soit ne soit résolu et en même temps ce
que ça montre aussi l'épisode l'épisode
indien c'est finalement la difficulté
des Britanniques à maîtriser le rythme
les modalités les détails des transfère
de pouvoir puisqueen fait une partie des
euh des des massacres qu'on qu'on vous
commence avant la décision de partition
commence avant le retrait britannique et
en fait vont forcer les Britanniques à
accélérer leur retrait et ce qui se
passe au final la partition était
absolument pas ce que ni Winston
Churchill ni Atel côté travailliste
souhaitait après effectivement l'art de
filer à l'anglaise parce que le l'Inde
joyau de la couronne reste et demeure un
des des un des grands membres un des
poids lourds du commonws qui à l'époque
se transforme et on va revenir sur le
commonws pourquoi avoir choisi de
commencer par l'Inde parce que le
contexte politique le justifiait en 47
alors c'est effectivement en parti euh
euh ce ce ce pointlà parce que ce qu'on
trouve finalement ce qui explique euh
cette idée persistante enfin qui
maintenant est un petit peu remise en
question mais d'une décolonisation
britannique réussie plus pacif ouais
c'est l'exemple indien vu
rétrospectivement et
donc le le documentaire en commençant
par là prend quelque chose qui est
finalement peut-être mieux connu que ce
qui se passe ensuite au Kenya ou à
Aiden mais en en montrant l'envers et
pas pas simplement
le la la rétrospective et
historiographique pendant longtemps et
politique puis les véité d'indépendance
en un donc commencé dans l'entre de
guerre notamment évidemment avec avec
Gandi alors Pascal Blanchard nous dans
le même temps et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure on se met en tête dès 46 de
reconquérir l'Indochine qui avait été
ellemême conquise par par les Japonais
alors là on a on a deux stratégies
complètement inverses comment il faut
comprendre passe en France à compar avec
ce qui se passe côté au départ ell sont
assez similaire au départ les Français
comme les Anglais pensent qu'ils vont
reprendre la situation en main il faut
remarquer aussi qu'en ad Chine vous
n'avez pas la même complexité qu'en Inde
qui est aussi une complexité ethnique et
religieuse qui va très vite rendre la
machine totalement tectonique et
intenable n'oublion pas aussi que les
Britanniques comme les Français sortent
et serent de cette guerre faut voir ce
faut imaginer ce qu l'Angleterre à ce
moment-là l'Angleterre n'a pas les
moyens d'une guerre sur le
sous-continent indien tout simplement la
France pense qu'elle a les moyens elle
d'une guerre en indochchine ce qui est
très différent comme analyse stratégique
donc les Français pensent que ils
peuvent imposer par la force de rester
autour de ces trois pays que sont le
Vietnam le Cambodge et le Laos et tenir
le continent en main ce que ne c'est pas
le cas tout de suite des Britanniques il
se rend bien compte que c'est à la fois
le joyau on n arrête pas de le dire mais
c'est immense l'Inde donc tenir
militairement un tel territoire à avec
le conflit religieux et avec comme vous
l'avez très bien dit c'est pratiquement
déjà 15 ans de lutte politique sur le
territoire avec Gandi mais c'est pareil
en indchine n'oublions pas que les
premiier rvoltes c'est les années 1930
les Français quelque part sont plus
prétentieux que les Britanniques ils se
disent on va y arriver on va arriver à
tenir peut-être avec l'aide des
Américains dans le contexte de la guerre
froide d'ailleurs ce qui va arriver très
très vite puisque dès 4950 les
Américains vont totalement financer la
guerre française faut pas l'oublier mais
à ce moment-là on est en 46 47 les
Britanniques n'ont ni les moyens ni la
capacité et puis ils sont aussi
entraînés par les événements quelque
part la situation leur échappe
totalement sur le territoire donc on
voit qu'il y a une volonté initiale
semblable deux grands empires qui
veulent garder deux de leur joyaux
peut-être une notion géographique la de
Chine est à peu près 1/5e de la taille
de ce qu à l'époque l'empire des Indes
donc une capacité militaire de le faire
avec quand même d'un côté une
décolonisation côté britannique qui se
sole de bah par une partition d'un pays
sans vraiment prendre parti à cette euh
la finalité de cette partition et puis
euh côté français qui qui se Solle par
une défaite militaire une défaite
militaire et et et en même temps dans le
cadre de la guerre froide un
enchaînement qui va après basculer sur
le continent africain c'est-à-dire qu'
on voit bien et d'ailleurs la perte
aussi pour les Français des conttoirs
des Indes parce que tout le monde a
oublié he a des français quand est-ce
qu'il on perdu les ctoirs des Indes tout
le monde a oublié à quel moment c'est
arrivé juste au lendemain de la guerre
nochine et donc vous avez si vous
préférez cette similitude qui est
intéressante et puis vous avez surtout
quelque chose qu'il faut que nous en
mesure c'est que l'année 46 47 c'est
déjà plus ce qui se passe en 49 50
n'oubliez pas qu'en 49 la Chine
populaire rentre dans le jeu des grandes
nations en 46 47 l'Asie est encore en
situation je dirais personne sait trop
comment elle va bouger en terme
d'événement et l'Inde est aussi un
détonnateur de tout le continent de ce
mouvement des indépendances avec les
Philippines à côté qui est lié à
l'empire américain on oublie aussi
toujours de penser que les Américains
ont aussi un grand empire colonial et
les Philippines et nind c'est vraiment
le détonnateur sur le continent de ce
qui va se passer ensuite oui vous voulez
rajouter quel pars j'allais simplement
pour souligner un un point que vous avez
évoqué je crois qu'il faut insister sur
la force euh des des mouvements
nationalistes indiens et en fait des
concessions qui ont été obtenues à la
fois euh à la veille de la guerre donc
l'autonomie des provinces elle se fait
en en
1937 et puis des concessions qui sont
obtenues des britanniques pendant euh
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale euh
notamment sur le statut de de de de
Dominion donc quelque chose de de une
autonomie au moins interne et
externe voilà donc la la force des
mouvements nationalistes est
effectivement très très importante on va
voir un deuxième extrait du documentaire
c'est la reine ellisabeth i nous sommes
en 1953 elle vient d'être couronnée un
reine d'Angleterre et voilà ce qu'elle
le dit à propos du
commonws
mais des paroles aux actes il y a un
gouffre et le discours idéaliste de la
souveraine raisonne comme un V pieux il
quo s'interroger sur ce le Common Wells
alors le comm c'est un club finalement
j'ai appris lorsquon appartient commonwe
celui-ci n'apporte aucun avantage
commercial aucune baisse des droits de
aucun accord de coopération civile ou
militaire c'est un véritable club
pourquoi est-ce qu'on adhère au commonws
à quoi a servi le commonws dans le cadre
de cette opération de décolonisation
britannique alors il y a quelque chose
dans le le discours de la reine qu'on
qu'on vient d'entendre qui je pense est
extrêmement important elle elle en parle
à un moment comme d'un concept et en
fait c'est effectivement un projet
politique et qui est alors certes mis en
place c'est qui répond à un certain
nombre d'intérêts des des Britanniques
donc c'est la la vitrine dont on parlait
tout à l'heure mais en fait c'est un
projet qui est aussi porté qui éé
soutenu dans l'entre de guerre par
notamment l'Australie le Canada la
Nouvelle-Zélande il faut absolument pas
l'oublier à cette époque là l'Afrique du
Sud alors les les valeurs portées par le
commonw sont très contradictoire avec ce
qui se passe sur le terrain ensuite au
Kenya Malaisie c'est toute la
démonstration du film qu'on a vu comment
explique cette dichotomie finalement
alors en fait les le la définition du
commonoels en terme de de valeur elle
est très très tardive le vraiment
officiellement le le moment où on la
trouve c'est
1971 quand les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement se se
réunissent à à Singapour ouais avant ça
c'est en fait une euh communauté de
territ ire autonome égo enroit mais lié
par la couronne un attachement donc il y
a un attachement impérial qui reste qui
reste fort et qui est finalement une
manière pour
lesurer cette idée de l'Empire auprès
des Britanniques c'est ça le commonws
alors une structure qui permet de de
faire perdurer ce ce rêve d'un impérial
britannique alors c'est pas il y a
effectivement notamment dans
après les années à partir des années 60
j'allais dire cette cette cette idée de
rêve mais avant je crois que c'est
beaucoup plus
pragmatique c'est une manière de
négocier en fait donc c'est une manière
de négocier pour les Britanniques et
c'est une manière de négocier à la pour
finalement les autres membres mais aussi
les colonies donc pour revenir par
exemple à à nerou dont on parlait oua
nerou se sert du fait que il accepte de
rentrer dans le commonws
pour obtenir aussi davantage de
concession de la part des Britanniques
euh il y a ce moment très important en
1949 quand l'Inde devient République et
les Britanniques changent le statut de
la du monarque de façon à accepter la
Première République qui est la
République indienne alors côté français
il y a d'abord l'Union française ça
c'est la 4e République euh les jalons a
d'ailleurs été posé par de Gaul on peut
dire les choses comme ça mais elle est
dans la constitution de la 4e he cette
Union française et puis ensuite 58 de GO
le retour au pouvoir et cette fois c'est
la Communauté française qui remplace
cette fameuse Union française alors
c'est quoi ce sont des fédérations on
veut on veut maintenir sa souveraineté
Coutte que goûte sur notre empire aussi
côté français durant cette période on
prépare l'Union française on change pas
grand-chose si ce n'est le nom et
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'état indépendant à
l'intérieur ni même d'État reconnus mais
d'une certaine manière c'est une
évolution pour dire on garde le le
mécanisme en changeant le nom du
spectacle parce que l'Union française ne
change pas beaucoup la réalité si ce
n'est les quatre départementalisations
ce qui est fondamental à comprendre
puisque ça devient une sorte de modèle
d'assimilation possible Guadeloupe
Martinique Réunion etiguillan on dit
voyez si vous évoluez en commun nous
pourrions tendre tous vers une forme
d'indépendance la communauté c'est autre
chose la communauté on commence à parler
d'État indépendant bien sûr la dochine a
disparu elle n'est plus dans le modèle
puisqu'on parle essentiellement pour les
États africains mais il y a cette idée
que des États libres ou qui vont devenir
libres ou qui vont bientôt être libres
vont pouvoir ensemble un peu comme le
Comand fonctionner ce rêve a duré à
peine une année n'oublions pas très vite
tout ça s'effondre d'abord parce que les
États vont profiter de la mise en place
de la communauté pour justement prendre
leur indépendance et partir on
remplacera la chose par la
France-Afrique d'une certaine manière
système informel et exactement comme les
Britanniques on va raccrocher nos vagons
plus tard dans les années 70 avec la
francophonie c'est qu'on va se dire les
Britanniques ont trouvé une idée qui est
géniale c'est sans véritablement avoir
de lien officiel ils arrivent à
fabriquer une sorte de communauté de
fait parce que chacun il trouve son
intérêt comme dans un club votre
expression est parfaite on vient dans ce
club parce qu'on va négocier des choses
mais alors nous ce club nous français on
n pas réussi à le créer on on n pas eu
l'équivalent du Common Wells qui aurait
pu être une solution politique peut-être
pour mais on l'a fait différemment la
Francophonie qui est arrivé à postériori
regardez les accords bilatéraux avec
tous les pays à la fois les accords de
défense qu'on passe avec pratiquement
tous les pays africains francophones et
les accords d'immigration parce que
n'oublion pas qu'ussi à l'intérieur du
Common comme à l'intérieur de l'espace
francophone ça permet à des populations
de circuler et de migrer vers la France
qui sont fondamentales dans les enjeux
de ces pays donc on va enf compte imiter
le commonwealf à d'autre façon comme
toujours les Français c'est toujours
très compliqué on comprend rien mais en
même temps ça fonctionne un peu pareil
des accords spécifiques on se retrouve à
l'ONU quand c'est des grands moments on
a des accords très particuliers sur les
accords bilatéraux militaires
économiques on continue à voir notre
coopération je rappelle la cébre
histoire c'était les mêmes coopérants en
58 en 62 et en 68 les gens restent sur
le territoire et on va donc retrouver un
mécanisme qui va être assez proche et
chez les Français la francophonie va
devenir l'idéologie on va dire qui
fédère indirectement ces vieux relicat
d'Empire chez les Britanniques ça s'est
fait ça donne le sentiment de cette fait
beaucoup plus en continuité alors que
pendant très longtemps le commonwolf
c'est assez vide en terme de mode de
fonctionnement en terme d'action
impression que ça donne effectivement
oui mais il y a une reine au-dessus
c'est la grande différence avec nous les
français qui changont beaucoup à
l'époque rappelez-vous la 4e République
c'était quand même les les régime se
succédait à part le tente de Gaulle qui
va imposer sur ces décennies c'est les
années 60 une refonde d'un système pour
arriver après à au système qu'on connaît
encore jusqu'aux années 90- 2000 la
France Afrique n'a pas disparu
immédiatement le Kenya la Malaisie sont
les les exemples qui sont mis en avant
dans ce dans ce film pour illustrer la
la répression qui a sé VI dans ces pays
contre les indépendantistes he pour
schématiser les les choses c'està dire
que ce sont les seuls pays qui ont subi
de telles répressions parmi les colonies
britanniques après guerre ou est-ce que
et que pour le reste finalement les
choses se sont plutôt bien passées alors
c'est
effectivement un les deux deux des
grands terrains où il y a eu sur une
période très longue puisqueen en fait en
en Malaisie c'est finalement de 1948
jusque finalement après c'est après
l'indépendance que réellement le toutes
les lois relatives à à l'état d'urgence
vont vont vont cesser et et au Kenya
pareil sur toute la période des des
années 50 et et plus donc c'est des
exemples qui qui sont significatifs à la
fois en terme de de dureté de la
répression de de globalité de de la
répression on voit que ça touche et les
les groupes armés et la population
civile de façon très directe et ça va
toucher ces pays aussi de de de façon
durable dans leur dans leur économie
dans la répartition des des terres et
aussi dans les réconciliation fait ou
pas
faite al il y a l'inverse de la ce qui
s'est passé en Malaisie au Kenya euh il
y a des décolonisations qu'on peut
qualifier de réussi sans heure du côté
britannique alors il y a un certain
nombre de déc colonisation ou peut-être
d'ailleurs de d'indépendance plutôt que
de de
décolonisation qui se passe finalement
de façon assez assez concerté alors ce
qui veut pas du tout dire qu'il y a pas
de violence de répression de moment
d'ailleurs y compris d'utilisation des
des forces de Poce de cette volonté des
des Britanniques de garder la main m sur
les les États en question j'imagine
absolument donc c'est le le cas au au
Ghana c'est vrai que après c'est aussi
un empire qui est vaste et moins les
territoires notamment dans les années 70
sont importants et stratégiques plus les
Britanniques donnent
l'indépendance facilement mais dans les
années 50 60 la violence est là parce
que l'État colonial est un état
répressif et violent h alors on a perdu
le conflit en
Indochine en revanche 1960 ça c'est une
année c'est un marqueur hein pour la
décolonisation française 14 colonies ou
territoires sous domination française
deviennent indépendantes et est-ce qu'on
peut dire que là les choses se passent
bien ou euh bah c'est pareil que les
Britanniques on a l'image que d'ailleurs
dans les maneles scolaires si vous
disais bien souvent la leçon s'appelle
les décolonisations pacifiques alors
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe à
Madagascar en 47 vous dites ça commence
quand même un peu violemment on estime
que sonentre 30000 et 90000 morts ouais
le Cameroun c'est quand même une guerre
qui commence en 55 qui était une
ancienne colonie allemande le Cameroun
exactement et qui a une histoire qui est
en fin de compte méconnue parce que la
guerre d'Algérie a totalement caché la
guerre du Cameroun alors que la guerre
du Cameroun 1 a lieu jusqu'aux
indépendan puisqu'elle va faire
s'effondrer l'UPC avec les la la il y a
la violence de ce conflit mais on va
même continuer à soutenir Aido et le
régime en place jusqu'en 1965 donc là on
voit que c'est un conflit qui s'installe
dans le temps long puis ça oublie le
Nord Côte d'Ivoire par exemple au près
de 1000 villages ch brûlés en fait on se
rend compte c'est exactement comme les
Britanniques vous avez vous prenez un
pays comme le Sénégal vous vous dites
bon bah décolonisation plutôt pacifique
entre guillemets si vous prenez des pays
comme l'ex sououdan qui devient le Mali
des pays comme le Nord Côte d'Ivoire si
vous prenez le koun si vous voulez pas
la Madagascar ça ne marche pas on voit
bien que c'est chaque territoire chaque
pays qui doit être regardé à l'ône de ce
qui s'est passé et donc il y a des pays
où ça été très violent d'autres pays où
c' été plutôt des répression d'ordre
politique une mamise où on a mis en
place des régimes amis comme on dit
aujourd'hui et qui vont rester très
longtemps amis et dans d'autres cas B il
va yir Afrique ouis exactement il va
avoir des guerres de vér le Cameroun est
une guerre dont commence à peine
aujourd'hui à mesurer les effets si on
devait la la mettre à l'échelle de
grandeur de de ces conflits c'est à peu
près la moitié des morts de la guerre
d'Algérie et aucun Françis n'a ça en
tête on l'a pas en tête et des
populations civiles alors ce qu'on a
surtout en tête c'est la guerre
d'Algérie département français qui
d'ailleurs avait le le plus grand nombre
de colons he parmi 1 million de colons
là c'est une tâche dans l'histoire
totalement et et et elle perdu hein
d'une certaine manière aujourd'hui ça
c'est le grand échec après l'Indochine
bien entendu et là aussi c'est une
défaite militaire c'est une défaite
militaire c'est un échec c'est la
colonie qui est la plus proche c'est un
département français vivent plus d'un
millions de Français et en même temps
aussi de Juifs nons pas qu' sont sur
cette terre depuis très longtemps donc
c'est un choc proche qui d'ailleurs qui
est assez étonnant parce que il y a une
colonie très proche de l'Algérie dans
l'histoire britannique c'est la rodésie
où en rodésie ça va il va se passer en
fin compte ce coup d'État ce pouch qui
Nura pas marché en France où des
Européens vont prendre le pouvoir en
rodésie c'est une indépendance bizarre
puisque c'est une indépendance blanche
c'est en fin de compte le pouvoir blanc
qui se détache de la Couronne et qui
prend une forme d'indépendance
complètement incroyable et qui devient
en fin de compte une colonie blanche
l'Algérie tel qu' nous l'a oublié mais
il y a eu des tentatives de coup d'état
pour qu'àun moment l'Algérie
pratiquement puisse pour pourquoi pas
être géré ou gouverné par ses colons
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a rappelé
de Gaul exactement voyez les
similitudes les similitudes entre les
deux empires sont beaucoup plus proches
que des fois on l'imagine parce que la
cartographie des décolonisations
britanniques est en fonction des
territoires très différent il y a pas
une manière d'avoir décolonisé et très
souvent ce sont quand même souvent les
événements territoriaux la typologie qui
va influencer la manière de sortir d'une
colonie absolument et je crois que par
exemple pour pour l'Afrique il faut
aussi bien avoir en en tête le fait que
dans un certain nombre de cas c'est des
c'est des territoires qui sont contigus
que les Français les Britanniques
observent de très près ce qui se passe
dans chacun des deux empires voire sur
certains points collabore envoie des
missions d'observation y compris
militair et que dans les Oubliés parce
que finalement je crois que l'art de
filer à l'anglaise c'est aussi ce qu'on
a peut-être pas retenu ce qui a été
perdu dans les mémoires et effectivement
l'exemple du Cameroun il y a le Cameroun
anciennement britannique don les
Britanniques sont sont partis alors
effectivement sans vouloir s'imposer
c'était c'était pas un territoire qui de
ce point de vue làà les les les
intéressaient mais dont on voit avec
entre autres alors sans faire de de
comment de de
continuité trop trop généralisante mais
mais voilà la crise actuelle dite
anglophone au au Cameroun montre aussi
les les problèmes de cette
décolonisation qui pourtant semblait
plus peut-ê peut-être négocié ou
Pacifique qu'ailleurs ça a très mal
préparé le départ sur le Cameroun et
toutes les conséquences que
qu'aujourd'hui encore on a frontialère
notamment en terme de population en
terme de d'États qui ne sont pas des
états parce que les frontières ont été
pensées par le système colonial et dans
le casadre du Cameroun encore plus
puisque c'était des mandats dans la
vérité les Anglais et les Français mais
ce que vous avez dit est très important
le Ghana par exemple qui va être un des
premiers à avir son indépendance va être
aussi un modèle pour les nationalistes
africains francophones si vous regardez
la cartographie c'est simple le Ghana en
gros il est au milieu de la of française
l'Afrique occidentale française donc
tout le monde va regarder ce que fait
Gana et comme le Ghana a un leadership
politique très fort notamment dans le
monde noir tout le monde va regarder le
mécanisme qui a réussi à imposer le
rapport de force Gana ça va influencer
énormément les voisins français pour se
dire ça c'est une voie à la fois négocié
de rapport de force qu'il faut savoir
développer avec les Français ce que va
très bien comprendre par exemple la Côte
d'Ivoire de fois dernier extrait du
documentaire nous sommes en 1982 c'est
la guerre des malwin à l'autre bout du
monde les malwiin une poignée d'î restée
sous sa tutelle sont envahis par
l'Argentine
sans attendre les forces armées de Sa
Majesté sont expédiées dans l'Atlantique
Sud pour défendre l'intégrité du
territoire et voler au secours de ces
[Musique]
habitants après 10 semaines de combat et
plus de 900 morts le dernier conflit
colonial livré par la Grande-Bretagne
s'achève sur victoire alors il y a
presque 40 ans hein maintenant les
Malouines euh néanmoins c'est la
dernière guerre livrée au nom de la la
colonisation ou de la décolonisation je
sais pas comment on peut dire les choses
euh en tout cas les Britanniques étaient
très fiers de cette victoire 3000
habitants au mallowin ils ont déployé
euh des dizaines de milliers de soldats
sur place hein les Britanniques avec un
retour triomphal de de cette guerre qui
a fait tout de même 900 morts ils en
sont fiers de cette guerre des malwin
les britannique aujourd'hui encore c'est
la voilà ça ça a du sens aujourd'hui
alors c'est à l'époque et c'est quelque
chose qui qui reste présenté comme une
guerre de de défense davantage queune
guerre de de décolonisation mais à
l'époque déjà il y avait en fait une une
majorité de de Britanniques qui auraiit
souhaitit qu'on fasse appel aux Nations
Unies que ce soit en fait quelque chose
de beaucoup plus négocié et ce que ça
soulligne à l'époque mais je crois aussi
à l'heure actuelle avec les débats qui
se poursuivent sur l'Empire les mémoires
de l'Empire au uni c'est l'impact des
médias parce que en fait la la guerre
des malwin elle est portée par le par la
en partie par la presse par la
télévision on voit Marc tcher en habit
guerrier on l'a mise en scène cette
guerre voilà et et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment le le rôle des il y a beaucoup
de nostalgiques de l'Empire britannique
aujourd'hui de l'autre côté de la Manche
j'ai vu qu' il y avait un sondage qui
était publié récemment dans The Guardian
qui disait qu'un quart de la population
britannique a a une nostalgie pour
l'Empire britannique aujourd'hui encore
alors effectivement il y a des sondages
qui montrent à la fois une nostalgie et
à la fois une fierté dans ce que
l'Empire a pu être et dans ce que les
Britanniques y ont fait en même temps il
y a aussi certaines analyses qui tendent
à nuancer ça et dans les débats très
relatifs au brexit sur la grandeur de
l'Empire il y a aussi en fait une
volonté peut-être d'oublier l'Empire
avantage que d'en avoir une une
nostalgie alors en France nous avons les
drumcom HE les départements et régions
d'outremer et collectivités d'outrem
anciennement les DomTom hein est-ce
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de de colonies
de territoirees sous l'autorité
britannique aujourd'hui comme c'est le
cas en France et on va revenir juste
après avec Pascal Blanchard alors il
reste effectivement des des territoires
d'outrem
euh un petit peu partout alors
stratégiquement c'est extrêmement
important ça c'est vu au moment de la
guerre des malwiines
il y a des territoires très contestés
notamment Diego Garcia dans les îles
Chagos dans l'océan indins
important mais elles sont moins
important elles sont surtout pas
représenté au Parlement britannique et
elles sont dans l'ensemble autonome
elles ont d'ailleurs à l'exception de
Gibraltar pas autonome sans vééité
d'indépendance c'est ça se marque à
différents moments mais dans l'ensemble
ça apparaît relativement peu alors c'est
vrai que l'ACT de ces derniers jours
nous a ramené à l'oreille des véités
d'indépendance du côté de certains de
ces territoires français cette fois hein
c'est vrai en Guadeloupe c'est vrai en
Martinique en Polynésie
on a encore un problème avec ces
territoire d'outrem du côté de la
métropole est-ce que ces territoires
vont doucement mais sûrement vers une
indépendance les historiens sont mauvais
pour prédire l'avenir mais en tout cas
l'histoire est longue puisque ces
territoirees était déjà dans les années
50 souvent en combat politique
rappelez-vous la PO
rappelez-vous les Antilles la Guyane
sont des territoires qui en fait n'ont
pas obtenu leur indépendance donc il y a
une historicité qui s'est ét allée dans
le temps rappelez-vous dans les années
800 il y a des bombes de l'arc pour
revendiquer les indépendants donc ce
processus est loin d'être terminé
plusieurs référendum ces dernières
années nous ont encore fait des bat donc
l'histoire est loin d'être terminée mais
la France a trouvé une manière de garder
ces terre avec une grande autonomie on
le voit en Polynésie avec le statut de
la Polynésie je pense que beaucoup de
territoires vont évoluer vers une
intègre indépendance à travers une forme
de descendre une autonomie forte en même
temps Mayot est devenu département
français dans les même six dernières
décennies donc c'est plus complexe qu'on
peut l'imaginer parce que en fonction
des territoires les revendications ne
sont pas les mêmes est-ce que vous
diriez aujourd'hui que notre classe
politique a retenu les leçons de ce qu'a
été la décolonisation française depuis
45 oui et non elle a retenu l'idée que
je pense aujourd'hui que ce temps était
terminé que notre classe politique avait
été très aveugle pendant la 4è et sacrme
République et qu'elle aurait pu prévoir
un autre avenir que celui du conflit de
sacrifier par exemple une génération
d'appelés français de 2 millions
d'appelés de réappelés qui ont fait des
guerres inutiles et qui ont sacrifié
toute leur jeunesse pour ça je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une prise de
conscience de ça parce qu'on peut en
parler maintenant et que ça était un
vrai trauma des deux côtés de l'autre
côté je pense que très peu de leçons é
retenu sur le sens politique de ce qu'on
était les indépendants c'estàdire que
les gens n'ont pas encore imaginé
comment en finin de compte il y a un
paradoxe une république paye des droits
de l'homme qui quelque part annonce que
la colonisation doit amener vers une
forme d'égalité et qui d'e certaine
manière par les armes ne veut pas partir
alors nous les français on a quand même
été très très fort les Portugais aussi
nous sommes les deux empires qui ont été
les plus violent l'Indochine on vient de
le dire le Cameroun l'Algérie la Tunisie
le Maroc donc là on je pense qu'on a pas
encore retenu les leçons et parce qu'on
est certainement encore dans la
mythologie Gauliste où le général de
Gaul aurait amené les indépendances et
donc cette mythologie a un peu sauvé
l'honneur de la France et le regard que
la France a et je pense qu'il va falloir
encore attendre une bonne décennie pour
qu'il y ait des hommes et des femmes
politiques et une génération qui
commence à regarder autrement ce qu'on
été les indépendances c'est la même
chose peut-être qu'en Angleterre sal va
oublier d'autres on la nostalgie et
d'autres commencent à avoir un regard
luci et ben ça sentrechoque encore dans
nos opinions publiques aujourd'hui
confirmez absolument et ça se voit très
bien dans les débats actuels sur
finalement qui est pour revenir à ce que
vous disiez au au départ Winston
Churchill la répression en en Inde d'un
côté la grande victoire de la seconde
guerre et on voit que dans les mémoires
et dans les différentes identités
nationales ça continue de voilà d'être
d'être problématique donc
à tout à fait les discussions
continueront bon on en restera là c'est
la fin de cette émission merci vraiment
un grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc consacré à la
décolonisation vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadog sur Twitter bien entendu
nos invités pourront réagir bien entendu
aussi à ce que sont vos réactions merci
aussi à Selma sali qui comme à
l'habitude m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission prochain rendez-vous avec
desbadog ça sera la même place à la même
heure et toujours avec son documentaire
et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]